[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
moi je n'ai je pas la moindre parcelle
de volonté j'ai toujours suivi les
conseils de maman
j'ai apprécié votre maman une b2
exceptionnel c'est vous qui dites je
suis quand même de juger
au fait où
déjà
[Musique]
tu sais qu'un jour tu te fais pas le
nier
[Musique]
au
ciel ma mère alors marcel la jeunesse
bonsoir jean clairement bonsoir pour soi
alors marseille se faisait souvent
doubler des films porno comme ça de
temps à autre mais ce n'est pas une
spécialisation le doublé qui par exemple
on est un peu dans la vie comme ça la
vie non ça j'ai pas j'ai pas fait que du
porno loin de là dieu merci d'ailleurs
j'ai doublé pas mal de films
et ce qui paraît aberrant d'ailleurs
c'est que j'ai doublé les premiers
premier premier film dé marilyn monroe
et vous la voix française de maman au
départ oui quand elle était venue de toc
ce repas ouais et puis après quand elle
est passée vedette fox c'était une autre
camarade qui était remarquable de sud et
bien tu je double et audrey heures n'est
alors maintenant ils y ont pris de l'âge
quand même alors les derniers que je
vous blessez madame chez les we need r
je ne sais si vous
fait c'est ça qui est amusant dans cette
profession d hier jean fait souvent des
films pornos j'aime ça non pas très
chaud par une [__] temps où il y en
avait beaucoup et puis le marché je
pense c'est râlant fait ça très bien on
essaie de travailler lignes épaisses et
quand vous faites le bruit la série ça
là on travaille à l'image d'un style
n'est pas toujours drôle cette grand
mère je suis grandement il s'agit au
petit enfant fait un bail le gourmand je
ne sais pas le doublage ou notre
classement général mais pas le port d'un
lot de toute façon je dis bonjour et
j'ai mes petits-enfants détiennent cette
voie là mais le film s'appelle
remplissez moi j'sais titre as est
encore jeune à ses seniors soit ou non
mais je suis là et particulièrement ses
brosses à dents mais ça serait
fastidieux et puis c'est tout oui un
rôle à la la la moi j'ai pensé que j'ai
ça tout le temps dont je
vous avais vraiment l'air de savoir bien
de faire c'est un métier je ne peux dire
si vous êtes avec un homme dans un livre
allait faire les bruits de type dha
croire que vous lui donnez beaucoup de
plaisir finalement formation protège
avait pas pensé une spéciale bout parce
que finalement le type croire que vous
devez beaucoup plaisir alors qu'il vous
fait aucun effet finalement que vous
êtes capable de faire tous les bruits de
la jouissance du plaisir on est
l'invention quand même
vous n'avez rien à vous
alors jean-pierre toi tu as fait cheveux
qu on m a fait une borne août 2003 2004
2003 2007 ces foules et mme rice en 17
ans en 17 ans alors là j'ai toujours
posé une question je vous dirais bon
c'est vrai qu'à les types qui font le
haut et d'autres qui font le bao oui le
problème et les cem c'est que souvent
les metteurs en scène où les producteurs
engagent des comédiens way qui sont
débutants donc ce n'est pas évident
qu'ils puissent fonctionner dans
l'érection facilement alors ils font ce
qu'on appelle la comédie ouais ils font
le début de l'érotisme soft qu'on
appelle et puis ensuite quand arrive le
garde le comédien se retire ou pendant
que la caméra - sur les visages
ensuite arrive le désert professionnelle
je m'excuse en amont je vous en prie qui
lui fait la pénétration oui
puisque ça se passe on continue et on
continue
on s'envoie pas que le jeune comédien de
20 ans qui est beau comme un prince qui
la caméra ensuite roman sur le visage
pendant ce temps le le vieux de la
vieille donc je fais partie c'est à dire
et la camera raw dessins dans la
position me roussin alors maintenant
deuxième question c'est quoi le secret
jacques comment tu peux demander comme
ça sur sur commande non puis gilles
puisque je vais te dire que là il ya
plein de téléspectateurs qui savoir
notamment au niveau déjà il ya
l'expérience ouais il c'est un joueur
déjà tu sais te mettre en condition
c'est facile je me laisse un peu moins
autant de secondes il y en a tant besoin
de deux heures ouais puis derrière moi
qui arrive jamais
puis déjà connu ce qu'ils beaucoup de
débutants lorsque déjà une présence une
personnalité un comédien connu un bon
vieux de la vieille qui a 15 ans de
métier que dix ans de métier qui sait
qu'il doit travailler avec cette
personnalité joie le gall garçons 1 il
peut pas sûr et ouais alors puis en plus
de ça bon moi j'ai une technique c'est
que ma technique est simple aussi
comment je pense à rien ouais que mes
partenaires me plaise ou pas je
travaillerai normalement que jude peso
pas ce que je fais ou parce que mon
problème toute façon auraient elles les
femmes avec une fille tu trouve plutôt
match oui je m'en fous j'arrive quand
même oui parce qu'il veut supprimer
péter une aubaine toit pour les femmes
non ça c'est ma vie professionnelle et
ma vie privée avant d'en parler
allez donc bien plus derrière moi j'ai
quand même bien de temps de yoga donc
sans transiger non non il s'est tu
pendant que c'est pas un problème
constatations c'est un problème de
mental je pouvais me concentrer pour
faire de ces noirs je suis moi même à la
limite mais est ce que comme ans était
venu je dirais ce qu'au départ comment
tu as tu as découvert que 20 dont pour
pour ce genre de film comment ça s'est
passé non ça s'est passé chez moi dans
le midi d'où je suis originaire au cape
town le plus grand centre naturiste de
vote ouais et j'étais très jeune à
l'époque
un jour metteurs en scène américains
riches mais hier on m'a demandé de faire
des films pour nous comment tu l'a
rencontré à la plage ah bon il invite
tout nu dans huit une image il a vu que
c'était particulièrement bien équipé
voilà alors il m'a dit il m'a dit est ce
que tu veux faire des films pour nous
alors moi en arrivant j'ai dit dans ma
campagne 2010 j'ai dit qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire eh ben il faut baiser était
payé un chili s'est dit finalement c'est
un bon job et je suis calme maïs et sa
mère vit tant par jour en usine reste
celle ci je suis plein et j'appuie sur
l'amour et des créatures d'olive a dit
d'accord
pour bonheur pour un grand bonheur pour
moi ç'a fonctionné au premier couvre 1
alors lorsque s'agit pas là des années
ce qu'on utilise à yopougon n'existait
pas en france cette tournée à l'étranger
d'abord oui et lorsque le hard est
arrivé en france pour moi c'est une
facilité parce que j'avais déjà deux
trois ans de métier derrière
depuis six états les cinq six mille fils
à ma carrière
cinq six mille fils j'ai vu passer
willy éleveurs non mais c'est pas de
mérite c'est mon métier j'ai vu passer
un millier de jeunes comédiens qui qui
au départ était inconnu qui entre temps
c'est devenu très célèbre atteint ou
certaines et puis bon moi je suis dans
la vie dont il sent bien c'est vrai que
des fois quand le type vont arrive plus
à évacuer au bout de quelques scènes on
met du lait nestlé wii comprend fait
battre la gloire -neuf de la glère des
fous du lait nestlé oui ah bon bien sûr
on prend du lait fille la fille se met
ça dans la bouche son du moteur
d'accord on ouvre la bouche alors ça
cool et puis ça adacore cette apparente
de raconter tout ça devant marcel
elle était avant comme j'étais au
courant et c'est vraiment naze dix mois
alors jean-pierre l'acception à trahir
un secret mais ça excuse moi mais ton
sexe mesure combien
je ne sais pas d'être au 25 avait quand
même 25 23 faisait 2 entre les deux
sénateurs
alors est à la maison maintenant
dernière question comment ça se passe
très bien j'aime ma femme on fait
l'amour tous les soirs et elle sait ça
et elle c'est sale et très intelligente
là ont fait la différence professionnel
donc dépassé dire tu tournes toute la
journée le soir tu arrives tu remets le
couvert mais parce que ça n'a rien à
voir
ça n'a absolument rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
n
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
c
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sous oh
il
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
ans
ok un crs
m
[Musique]
ce soir là le quasar et aubin c'était
madonna par marie france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
michel poniatowski bonsoir merci d'être
robin c'est au foot ça vous change non
un peu ça vous va très bien gérard est
très sympathique mais trop cher depuis
quelques temps vous voit un peu moins
dans les médias est ce que c'est parce
que vous n'avez plus de fonctions
ministérielles bien entendu mais quand
même on est moins chouchou des médias
qu'à une époque est ce que parce que
vous avez fait des gaffes parce que vous
avez dit des gros mots ou des choses
comme ça les gars je n'en sais rien des
plus beaux mots suu kyi s'est appréciée
non c'est surtout parce que je suis
parlement européen que je voyage
beaucoup en europe et d'ailleurs aux
états unis en russie au japon et que
j'essaie de voir quelle est la situation
mondiale pour l'inviter mu analyser la
situation européenne car tout ça va très
très vite on assiste aujourd'hui aux
sept d'or aux victoires de l'entreprise
aux victoires de la musique alors nous
avons minuit on a décidé de créer un
pony adore
je suis venue de ces jeunes méfie et la
troisième à 3 décernés alors on n'a pas
demandé de le décerner ponner le ponia
d'or à l'homme politique de l'année à
l'écrivain de l'année et aux
journalistes de l'année alors à l'homme
politique de l'année
pour vous même politique de l'année
j'ai dit des fils de m ah bon
vous êtes les joueurs là non pas du tout
mais vais jouer mais je pense qu il a
même craqué mais aucun n'était alors à
l'étranger et prend dix ans à l'étranger
ni à gauche ouais c'est aller tout le
monde s'en trouvèrent tout le monde fait
quelques erreurs
à l'étranger je te fais vous ou sur le
dessin de riez vendée mon come on sera
encore là ce sera l'année prochaine il y
donnera le pony à doha labardin portant
la responsabilité de l'action c'est
l'année prochaine s'il est élu qu'on se
met alors à l'étranger des médias à
l'étranger il va nous dire gorba
tiennent exactement j'avais su alors
pourquoi pas normal que ça ait changé
lui disait des trucs
car chez eux il est entré
d'essayer de transformer un pays tu es
complètement ses rosés est complètement
bureaucratisé est complètement en dehors
du temps il faut bien réaliser que se
montre un poste passé dans la
civilisation scientifique qui cèdent les
dunes du siècle prochain et lui vit
encore en partie avec le 19e siècle et
demi alors pour gorbatchev voilà ce
continent passionné de villemagne adore
apparaît alors à l'écrivain un écrivain
avec les 22 d'année
[Musique]
il va me dire tahar benjelloun
non non non non non
non mais ne pourra pas mérité tahar ben
jelloun on dit qu'il a copié son livre
non épluchées par lui que john reade
pour montpellier ne sont pas ni adore
alors
leur maison
passé littéraire un livre d'histoire
peut-être n'ont pas terni de l'histoire
non mais si j'avais mais là je vais
tomber dans mes précieuses car ce
malaisie c'est tout ce qu'on voudrait
c'est ce serait à tuchan tu la wii pour
les normes dictionnaire qui l'a fait sur
le sur napoléon et toutes les peaux
canadienne aurait dû très clair c'est
vos ancêtres tout ça alors un
journaliste mme mounia d'or du
journalisme
et même peut-être à tesson pour avoir
sauvé sur provisions avant son journal
soit des griffes de goldsmith ont trouvé
preneur
vous n'habitez pas comment mais griffe
jimmy goldsmith de troupes qui s'est
très bien battu pour pour m miranville
quotidien alors maintenant on va faire
les antilles faire les antilles ponia
d'or alors les pony admet alors qu'un
homme politique à qui vous le donne à
riez le pire homme politique de l'année
vraiment celui qui est le plus nul
non c'est vrai
champion mais je pense que le plus
complet sur la plage
c'est probablement la joie ni à l'amour
on vous reconnaît là ça y est riou mais
c'est vrai bon c'est vraiment il va me
plaît on ne boit l'absence totale l'idée
c'est la répétition des d'hérésie
classique alors après un journaliste
serait plus mauvais journaliste baignade
est remuant mais ils vont se trouver à
l'humanité
il fait fort l'écrivain est plus
compact et un
non on va vous faire réagir sur
certaines sur un certain nombre de gens
voilà je vous donnais je vais citer une
liste de dosnon et puis il est le genre
vous avez donc réagir alors s'il vous
dit valéry giscard d'estaing que vous
répondez vous j'aime beaucoup les mme
bokova mais toujours beaucoup je les
aime beaucoup et je pense que c'est un
des hommes politiques les plus
intelligents les plus lucides que nous
ayons correspond pas au profil tu
aimerais que veulent les français mais
c'est l'homme le plus remarquable que
nous ayons sur la salle intime et variés
là dessus et non ça fonctionne toujours
par télépathie comme vous avez pu le
dire ces plaintes et les pâtissiers
giscard était
c'est vrai mais c'est plus que ça c'est
la classe et le jugement sur l'homme
paulo et aujourd'hui c'est encore plus
que ça oui moi comme minutes alors donc
vraiment barbares et montbard
même un bar sur la sécurité il s'est
probablement ce que nous pouvons avoir
de mieux pour gérer une telle étude les
français parce que ça serait quand même
giscard sinon
pour gérer la france à l'heure actuelle
c'est françois mitterrand
c'était
c'est un roman qui ne veut
je ne prends pas plus qu'ils puissent
apporter quelque chose d'important à la
france la france et qu'il a fait là
dernièrement je pense qu'il a assuré
l'unité française pendant les deux
années de cohabitation et c'était très
important en continu par les retards les
acteurs il faut qu'ils se forment en
cours dans sept ans peut mieux faire
dans 7 à vous prendre à lui de le faire
la faire je pense qu'il doit se forme
qui va amener qu'il pourrait prendre
complètement son métier c'est un très
bon ministre de l'intérieur un excellent
me de la verrière excellent là vous êtes
expert en la matière est selon vous
le meilleur
oui je crois alors du calme danger qu'un
jeune juge du sympathique façon
indépendante à lui
mais enfin tout ça c'est des points des
projets krasucki mauvais héros car
michel rocard les jeux m'ont dis moi tu
aimes pas tellement baiser parce que
d'un moyen de votre inscription vous
même ou est ce que tu es contre elle est
naturelle et sa nature ou d'un moyen de
contraception et peut-être s'ils
répondent pour une vie est en jeu
contraception par le pt c'est quoi
1984 jean luc maître thierry ardisson
interview sans anesthésie karen cheryl
questionner
ça donne quoi sean roosen toile un
questionnaire
non un coup de massue poisse ne vous
faites pas semblant d'être
violée c'est qu'ils m'ont quand même
fait saigner
je réclame un gros plan sur le doigt
elle seule m'ont fait signer
avant l'interview à l'heure actuelle il
serait tellement immonde c'est plutôt
vaginale okito riediennes comme une
fiole
ouais je trouve plutôt abruti mais on te
demande pas tant droiture original ou
clitoridienne à mes côtés mon cher ce
que ça va mal on a essayé mais j'ai pas
du tout envie
tu as compris la question absolument pas
différence le clitoris des vagins
absolument pas je n'aime ça seulement
pas compris encore absolument pas
pourquoi vous vous êtes jaloux qui
tenait à noter amalthée quoi je n'ai
absolument pas compris je ne sais pas de
quoi vous parlez tu te réveilles tu
comprends pas ce qui se passe mais ça
c'est pas très bien ce qui t'arrive à ce
que tu veux dire
bondy mois l'aliéner l'a pas déjà eu des
expériences homosexuelles
non c'est pas comme vous savez ça fait
15 ans n'ont jamais eu ça n'a jamais
proposé j'avais une fille quitte à
proposer quelque chose non même pas
celle à
celle à tout jamais proposé de coucher
avec elle par an
je n'ai jamais eu d'expérience de ce
genre de questions vous réservé à ces
personnes l'ancienne drôle je ne bois
pas je ne fume pas et je vous laisse
votre sens du club vas-y genou quoi vous
savez très bien qu'on nous appelle nous
encore
nous en quoi les kings non monsieur le
sanctus après serment mais le vent que
je restais en curieux de le dire d'abord
je n'achète pas j'en sais rien je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire si c'est
une verge rancune pour dénoncer après
est ce que tu es déjà les voir des
prostituées je ne m'appelle pas raul ça
manque tellement triste de vous voir là
dedans à ça la police au collégial et
bien lotis que les membres du plq a
servi de faire quoi quand on était
petits on voulait sauter karen cheryl
c'est pas vrai alors qu'on la défend
d'ailleurs la pure envie tu vois c'est
vrai
madame vous avez vous avez pu enlever
allusion à nîmes ou réparent si oui on a
du coup c'est tout vous avez choisi
comment pour les messieurs 1 comment tu
prends la pas dû en auditionné beaucoup
de ses seins alors comment réussit les
deux toiles propos de bec tu prends
garde fou mais tu prends moi je prends
la valise dans le seconde ouais quand tu
prends pour une émission non je prends
la porte et cas rien tu vois souvent non
tu vois jamais toi hein tu vois et voilà
c'est lui qui vous envoie alors que ça
irait bien à part tu n'aimes pas
j't'adore fait une grande carrière et
avec les trois profils adaptés la
question fait fondre son
plein de choses si c'est pas tout bien à
qui j'allais chez les menottes par
exemple d'accord tu fais l'autre et puis
j'aime aussi le jaune et le noir et pull
cachemire si vous voulez je peux aussi
vous payez une nouvelle machine à écrire
pendant les stages c'est plutôt comment
effectivement si on s'en sert avec un
doigt ça doit suffire ouais wasikowska
côte à l'os occuper le flot de la caisse
du thé acheter
sega fatah reste je t'ai dit là ce
estimé que la bière de super
à l'étoile argentée il doit certainement
être impuissant
après nos bons souvenirs c'était très
inspiré la gt pas vraiment respirer
j'étais plus distraits que maintenant
sûrement oui alors il paraît que tu es
devenu tout doux gentil gentil je suis
devenu hyper gentil on à dire tu donnes
l'exercice de style doit montrer de quoi
tu es capable mazouna or pas du tout
regarde maintenant bon déjà je suis à
10h30 bref de faire 1 8h30 je suis
devenu très doux voilà par exemple pour
faire un litre et demi par ton
animateurs ont six points comme en
passant mon interview quelqu'un a une
chanson en promotion en ce moment chez
polydor une très bonne maison excellent
excellent elle s'appelle comment ta
chanson à l'envers à l'endroit l'on
verra pas de commençons alors à l'envers
à l'endroit à l'endroit on comprend mal
envers pourquoi ça veut dire quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à pau
l'homme
shi
tous les deux de g
ouassou
shark son local
non moins
[Musique]
pour
mais là cette descente de police pendant
qu'elle me vend dix mois ce que signifie
sa longueur empêchement savent ce que
signifie à l'envers dans ma chanson oui
parce que j'ai déjà eu corinne charby
qui faisait pile ou face bon on s'est
douté un peu ce que ça voulait dire mais
à l'envers
[Musique]
2 d'où
que tu sais
n'importe où
[Musique]
encore
signifie à l'envers sont les coulisses
sulfureuse parfois de la vie un bon
ouais ouais alors je t'emmène par la
main par exemple et puis
tout a changé tout puisqu'à l'époque une
vidéo des cendriers sur la gueule et
puis maintenant mais toi tu faisais pas
mal non avec les personnes voudraient
canettes de bière je t'avais couper le
doigt je trouve que le brushing c'est
vrai qu'un ex distroll serait pas mal
[Musique]
comme ça
quand toi
[Musique]
ce qui peut tenir leur spleen l'air plus
rien dans ces salles changer les quotas
sont ravis de tenir parole de vie à la
mode à ta sentiment que tu vas finir
pour moi j'ai l'impression qu'en mettant
ce soir avec toi dans bad minuit je suis
parfaitement à la mode à bord ils
savaient pas que l'émission était démodé
ou alors c'est un scoop que tu m'aimes
bien sûr une fois encore de beaux lots n
est pas encore démodé alors tout va bien
g
[Musique]
je ne
non
sexuellement très tendre très contente
c'est là justement on aurait pu choisir
un autre arrêt sur image par exemple
tout à l'heure mais c'est une question
petit frigo d'un oui certes revu pas mal
avec ça fait et toi vous moi j'ai moi ça
va c'est quand il te comble temps jules
lavie nous conte en mettant jules
la finit en général pour longtemps jules
se demande bien sûr je t'ai répondu tout
âge tabor thaler
[Musique]
toilettes
qu'est ce que tu penses que pour le 20
heures 30 la paix près
avec toi bon j'aurai toujours envie de
se marier et regarde plus sage mais
est-ce que c'était déjà arrivé à l'inter
tu vas pas me dire ce rapport sur la
gueule cette fois ça serait trop facile
ouais c'est pas une expérience vécue un
qui chante des trucs tu connais pas mais
tout ce que je chante ça vient du vécu
ça c'est ça tu veux tu admets tu
reconnais ouais donc j'étais libre là
bas c'est fini
elles changent pas
mais non je pense
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai vu chez pivot la semaine
dernière par ya un moment qui est un peu
enfin peu gnangnan justement c'est quand
on parlait de l' aventure chez fauchon
comme d'un exploit militaire quand on
nous expliquait qu antoine de gaudemar
transmettant les messages entre les
ravisseurs de nogrette et elle est enfin
l agence de presse libération c'était un
exploit enfin vous qui avait passé
quatre ans dans une cellule de 6 mètres
carrés à 3000 m d'altitude à camiri ça
vous semblez pas un peu ridicule que
tout ça soit considéré comme un exploit
militaire pratiquement écouter
honnêtement oui je leur en veux pas
parce que je veux dire ici on crut
alors il s'exonère de croire encore
c'est un exploitant je crois qu'ils y
mettent un peu d'humour maintenant et
j'espère pour eux ouais et puis 68 c'est
parce qu'il s'est fait qui est important
c'est ce qui s'est senti ce qui s'est
passé après en profondeur le militaire
c'était dérisoire je crois qu'ils ne se
prennent pas au jeu espérant paraissent
j'espère aussi
vous avez déclaré han han 82 à montréal
qu'il fallait enlever absolument un
pivot le monopole l'arbitraire la
dictature sur le monde des lettres et
puis j'étais assez étonné parce que
l'autre soir quand vous avez débarqué
chez chez lui sur le plateau d'
apostrophes personnes en a parlé c'est
quand même un peu bizarre mais non parce
qu'on avait fait la paix d'abord vous et
c'est la paix y'avait j'arrive guerre
d'abord un élu une déclaration assez
sérieuses qu'il y avait une déclaration
d'abord un
on doit pas faire de déclarations sur
une situation française à l'étranger
j'avais commis une erreur j'étais pas là
pas du tout au canada officiellement
j'étais comme écrivain je pouvais parler
comme écrivain nomade tout de suite
échangé positions opposées mais le fait
que je collaborerai et collabore
toujours avec françois mitterrand donc
ça passait pour déclarations officielles
et c'était une erreur de ma part
le fonds où je crois je crois qu'il
avait toujours raison et que j'ai
toujours eue non c'est à dire je n'ai
jamais rien dit contre pivot jeudi qu'il
fallait beaucoup de pivot qui en avait
que ça devenait dangereux c'est tout
mais le var comme l'an dernier vous
aviez vous étiez mis d'accord pour pas
en parler d'une envie même pas reparlé
alors publié un bouquin que chez lui
j'aime bien s'appelle les masses je sais
pas pourquoi une jaquette d'ailleurs
parce que c'est beau la couverture de
gallimard n'ont mené le dessin de
picasso est encore plus beau à mon
accord alors c'est pas mal c'est un peu
comme mitterrand circulent dès que vous
arrêtez de faire biologique données
sympathique ne vous en faites pas non
slim à ben patte blanche où le temps
s'arrête alors mesdames si vous êtes
vachement bien sinon on assiste ici à si
vous êtes bien alors en plus vous vous
mettez tout le monde de votre côté parce
que dès le début vous expliquer cette
histoire qui est arrivé à beaucoup de
gens mais savourant chais pas ça vous
rend humain vous parlez de cette femme
avec laquelle vous avez vécu pendant dix
ans et puis un jour vous découvrez
qu'elle vivait parallèlement avec un
autre homme et que l'enfant vous avez eu
avec elle n'était peut-être pas le
n'était pas le vôtre quoi
tu es très indécent mais je crois que
c'est des choses qui arrivent ouais à
vous je ne sais pas à d'autres en tout
cas pour ça mais sans doute arriver moi
je n'ai peut-être pas appris
vous êtes un homme heureux vous espère
mais n'ont apporté de cette situation
qu'on peut dire banale qui tout de même
une souffrance qui est une crise de
confiance pas seulement une infidélité
c'est qu'on perd un peu perd pied corps
ouais et comment sait plus qui est
l'autre et que l'autre était qu un peu
comme un miroir on sait plus qui on est
soi-même
on a vraiment besoin d'abord de se
trouver des questions est-ce que ce que
je suis pas responsable de cette
situation est-ce que moi non plus est
pas trompé mon monde ouais je crois pas
qu'il ya des gens honnêtes et des gens
malhonnêtes ya pas les bons et les
méchants on est très ambigu tous mais
voilà aussi un peu un livre sur
l'ambiguïté il ya un truc quand même
dans votre bouquin vous dites vous
essayez de dire la vérité vous savez
bien qu'on peut jamais dire complètement
la vérité dans le rendu mais il ya un
truc moi qui manque dans ce livre c'est
la réalité du régime castriste ya quand
même des petites baraques à tous les
petits bureaux à tous les coins de rue
pour regarder ce que font les gens
savent où aller là bas non ah c'est pas
vrai c'est l'arrêt la réalité est qu'on
vous l'a dit noms tels que je les ai vus
dans le nouvel observateur sous la plume
de guy sitbon il faut parfois faire
alors non pas du tout là si il faut
parfois aller sur place le régime
castriste et pas l'enfer c'est pas le
goulag tropical comme on l'a dit mais
régime ennuyeux est comme tous types de
régimes où il se passe pas dégagé au
coin des rues il ya des petits bureaux
pour garder mais pourquoi il lançait
alors dans le nouvel obs avait pas le
droit de dire ce willy-brandt minutes le
nouvel obs ah ouais c'est pas mis nu
mais c'est un journal qui fait de
clichés aussi donc c'est non on va dire
que la réalité des chouettes sont plus
complets nyon le dis et je peux vous
garantir que on vit mieux à cuba qu'au
pérou où toi là mais je préfère vivre en
france où les régimes que nous avons
vous préférez ce qui s'est passé en
argentine avec raul alfonsin bien sûr on
est d'accord là dessus mais d'accord bon
vous avez beaucoup travaillé dans voter
parce que finalement vous êtes invité
tout le temps par les grands vous êtes
invités par castro est invité non c est
ce que vous allez dans des colloques à
new delhi
vous êtes à l'elysée et on a
l'impression d'une vie assez cfid
géraldienne à ces dandys finalement
encore une fois dans la bouche c'est pas
une mais vous allez quand même un côté
est ce que disait vraiment bosser dans
le devis écoutez je crois que vous avez
raison je crois que j'ai été très gâtée
mais c est que je reconnais qu'il ya un
côté people dans mon bouquin peut-être
dans l'émission vous faites aussi peu
agacé parce que je parle que des gens
connus cela dit je parle aussi d'autres
gens qui lui sont mois la femme dont je
fait le portrait n'est pas connu donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya ce côté là disons
que le pouvoir ça facilite les voyages
les rencontres et depuis 80 c'est vrai
qu'on prend beaucoup l'avion et qu'on
voit facilement les chaînes des termites
jeune et je suis chez invité chez machin
je suis invitée chez truc en fait on a
l'impression comme ça d'une vie facile
non elle est au quotidien tout de même
plus emmerdante que je ne le dis ouais
mais c'est vrai que j'ai été gâtée que
je sais qui est un côté enfant gâté que
je n'aime pas beaucoup sous cet aspect
dans les droits de l'homme pourquoi vous
dites que les droits de l'homme c'est la
mystification la plus sympa du moment
parce que s'ils reviennent seulement des
droits mais il ya des voix
premièrement parce que parler des droits
sans parler des devoirs c'est pas
sérieux nous les droits c'est on les
connaît les obligations payer l'impôt
faire son service militaire défendre la
patrie ça paraît un peu cucul mais ça
peut se faire et qu'on peut pas voir
l'un sans l'autre on peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre et visite
j'entends des vieux monarchistes me dire
sabre et bien je trouve que les
monarchistes ont parfois raison sur
certains points moi même j'ai je
reconnais que j'ai eu des faiblesses
monarchiste
et qu'il ya certains mon avis comme
bertrand renouvin que j'aime bien et je
considère que il ya beaucoup de
démocratie en europe qui sont des
monarchies jacques lang son temps à dire
que les pays les plus démocratiques
d'europe sont démarchés pas faux quel
plaisir et puis pour la politique
étrangère c'est très utile une famille
royale parce que ça que c'est quelque
chose d'un peu affective d'un peu
sentimental et puis parce que ça permet
de soulager des toutes les obligations
protocolaires les gens qui font le
travail un gouvernement c'est-à-dire les
premiers ministres et autres et en cinq
ans j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour la
façon dont les britanniques sont
présents partout à travers la princesse
anne la tante ursule la cousine la
duchesse de ceux ci etc ils sont partout
au pacifique en afrique etc c'est à dire
que l'angleterre est présente partout
outre une famille royale je trouve ça
très bien en plus légitimité continuité
tout ça me semble bien mais je me
console en pensant qu'on est dans un
régime monarchique république est si
mitterrand tellement de succès en ce
moment c'est sans doute parce qu'il a
pris une dimension en monarchique
tant que la monarchie à l'adhésion
populaire régulièrement contrôlés on
peut dire c'est une monarchie
républicaine alors dernière question
votre livre s'appelle les masses
d'enlever des masses comme ça bon
pour votre plus grand bien je pense mes
preuves et gardez votre moustache parce
que moi ce que j'aurais voulu voir
arriver c'est un régis debray beauzelle
il joue un peu plus longs qu'à l'époque
mais sans moustache c'était le moment de
la raser la moustache écoutez je me
garde ça le jour où j'aurai vraiment
besoin de me déguiser c'est-à-dire de
déguiser en ayant un vrai visage sans
moustache mais ça ce sera pour des
circonstances peut-être différente où
j'aurai vraiment besoin soit pour sauver
ma peau onze employés dans des endroits
où je veux pas qu'on me reconnaisse sont
ici ça va ce serait encore un jeu quoi
encore à une sorte de
d'artifice code sans lever la moustache
vous avez raison j'y tiens pas non il
est né à lille pour tellement il ya des
quand j'étais en taux et je me rasais
pas car j'avais une barre à la fin que
je pouvais pas sortir bakou apa la
moustache de les laisser votre cv cela
fait partie de votre image mais je
pensais vous auriez pu la rescousse et
vous avez raison j'y penserai pour le
prochain dakar
[Musique]
et bien voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
r
m
jamais
yahoo
du coup
[Musique]
en fait
à
[Applaudissements]
michael jackson ses héritiers perth
direction artistique d'un milite compte
christophe salengro pare-balles chamoux
si ça s'appelle je suis sentimentale et
c'est génial vraiment génial absolument
génial très très génial super junior
génial
[Musique]
bon
beaucoup
à mes rôles et c'est galère
[Musique]
en jeu
puis de crem je conduisais
[Musique]
oh
alors on recommence
[Musique]
je suis
sentie
mantra
en temps
tellement
sentimental
[Musique]
je t'aime on si fort
outil
content
la plus frappée
les vols
dans ce
[Musique]
puis tu te déshabille
alors j'en profite
[Musique]
je suis
sentie
montera
l'allemand
sentimental
ma
je t'aime ou si fort
on était
content
dans la bagnole l'on part toi
a radio
[Musique]
un
détour dans la forme
[Musique]
alors on recommence
oh
je suis sentimentale
[Musique]
tellement sentimentale
je t'aime si fort
mois et demi par mois et on
quand je suis sorti
[Musique]
le monde
jim mora
que ça me info
[Musique]
dans le monde
qui montera
c'est ma santé mentale qui ont trop nous
tellement
sandy montra c'est ma santé mentale
shampooing doux au talon
dimanche
ça va
on
[Musique]
christophe salengro on t'a vu dans la
pub on t'a vu dans gerflor aidant lanfry
tahiti d'une star de la publication de
l'enfer là
j'ai envie de faire autre chose puis
mots c'est aussi parce que je t'aime un
peu grillé sur des produits donc c'est
du coup je fais autre chose mais alors
tu à monter une maison de production
avec de l'épiné et bruckert voyez
d'autres personnes mais eux participer
plus sur la conception d'un de série de
50 short un programme court reibel short
qui dure 20 secondes avec canal plus
grands buteurs avec un sponsor qui
serait le mécano et ça s'appelle comment
cela explique itv que ça veut dire ce
qu'est spiky c'est le nom d'un
personnage un psychopathe de la
télévision qui habite dans le poste de
télévision et qui est un malade de la
télé crochet la télé équipe ira t on de
canal plus et qui fait la télévision
avec un grand a laissé une station
pirate qui vient se greffer sur canal+
voilà on va voir le premier à
l'antiquité
[Musique]
mais
et
ce afin d'avoir le deuxième spiky tv que
vous nous avez vous avez amené c'est
quoi le thème aspect qui fait toujours
la télévision de façon approximative qui
est tout seul et là c'est un peu
émissions religieuses mais en ce nouvel
an russe c'est un peu c'est une émission
religieuse vu par speedy glass et
d'apprécier après envie de créer un
personnage un peu comme pee wee comme ça
un personnage très dessinée fait oui pas
forcément un peu comme puis oui mais un
travail canal j ouer pas catholique café
un bar d'un oui bien sûr oui oh oui pour
le le le pâturage audiovisuel france
malaisie alors 2e ce piquet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle vous donnez pas la chaîne
jean louis aubert bonsoir
ça fait vraiment un ça fait comme à la
télé ordi on y tenait il à dire
quel bilan tu fais de la tournée au
bahreïn colas est terminée signal au
moins deux mois de décembre
je dois faire un bilan aiful façon qu'il
en soit cette
journée 91 une bonne journaliste est
bien pour nous c'était un re départ on a
traversé toute la france en jouant comme
ça
je sais pas quoi dire
mais dylan est il plus éclatée par
exemple
ou est-ce que c'était le mieux ou est-ce
que cela signale c'était bien pas un bon
la cigale c'est bien parce que paris ça
reste toujours surtout en fin de tournée
quoi ça reste une consécration mais on
donne tout ce qu'on a appris au cours
des concerts j'ai bien aimé la belgique
aussi que sa première fois de ma vie que
j'avais aller partout de télé ou un
téléphone en amérique vous allez en
australie vous n'êtes pas les finalement
c'était le japon c'est quand vous êtes
allé kong et au japon où il y avait en
australie je n'ai jamais et finalement
s'incliner
est-ce qui est éclatée refuse finalement
cela
j'aime bien en belgique parce que j'ai
remarqué pour la première fois de ma vie
ça va parler avant qu'ils étaient en
avance sur nous parce qu'il était
vraiment européen je regrette pas le
sabordage de téléphone quoi c'était à
refaire je referais la même chose
c'est pas si moh sabordage c'est un peu
un sabordage
ouais mais ça nage savez
comme cette couler un bateau qui va bien
on annule un bateau qui avait des trous
non j'ai jamais ça ne le savaient pas
encore arrivé de regretter ça m'est
arrivé de regretter que les gens restent
ils comprendront qu'on connaît pas
je n'ai pas envie de terminer quelque
chose qui avait toujours été bien pour
nous que ça devienne une banalité comme
il y en a plein
je vais revoir les autres taurine par
exemple tu l'as tu d'arbois tu
l'appelles tu commences à six mains je
l'appelle parle non non pas de nouvelles
non pas en soi on se croise quand m
qu'est ce que vous dites pas envoyé
comme ça l'école dont les superficies sa
tombe est un peu sa compagnie non parce
que dans qu'à travers les jeux
superficial ça ça m'arrive dans le
quotidien il ya par des shows sujet à
bruxelles par ivan sont les jambes on en
est leur moral et ça on va pas pourtant
ce qu'on doit quelques instants comme ça
et qu'on a vécu 15 ans ensemble on va
pas dire qu'à la base ce sera pire des
choses très profondes
m
et bertignac il a remué là
gratuit pas depuis deux mois donc
je ne sais pourquoi mais j'ai déjà s'est
enfermé chez lui tu penses que je
pourrais rejouer ensemble que certains
beatles ont joué ensemble à des moments
comme certains beatles à damon
et tu fais quoi en ce moment là
quand les beatles c'est quoi une des
pointures je sais pas il y en a un qui
sort un verset pas moi
bref tu fais quoi ce moment là je me
suis installé dans une usine qui
s'appelle lucine studio on a les filles
aux répétitions avec des machines et des
copains et on fait tourner des trucs on
s'amuse en ce moment c'est la musique
tous les jours et en fait on est censé
travailler vrai
pour les gens du
qui nous regardent professionnellement
on leur dit qu'on travaille en fait
sérieuse et août écoute moi en ce moment
que la musique
j'écoute toujours le double prince un
concert de kyo à orange aussi que j'ai
eu
par des biais détournés
on dirait de la console nes et super
jadis de tamla motown investi pour les
20e anniversaire ça ça tient la route
j'écoute toujours ça
l'album d'iggy pop scène bien lequel
dernier
presque tout j'aime bien les chansons
des équipes l'idiot le sport live j'aime
bien ils sont cons ça dort ce qu'il
écrit j'écoute aussi depeche mode le
dernier
c'est lassant tout l'album mais j'aime
bien quand même j'aime bien les paroles
aussi très simple très bien fait cette
alice et quoi téléphone à part un nom
c'est un essai de l'argent à la banque
non pas la vente dans un coffre non dans
ton jardin jeanne acheté ma maison
elle est bien ta maison ouais elle est
ou bien vous l'année elle est grande
c'est une usine aussi à l'enseignement
tue pas cette musique mélange la maison
urbaine c'est un grand appart quand on
appelle ça des lofts
et en fait ça nous a laissé sasha qu'un
peu près non par un énorme tas d'argent
ça fait combien pour que les gens
sachent que ça peut rapporter d'avoir
pété les plombs ça fait ils vont devenir
tous les ans 30 millions anciens ont dû
un ça va et puis de quoi de quoi faire
un nouveau groupe par sa chance pendant
le 200 alors ce qui fait souffrir c'est
un peu un rêve parce que dans les
réalisateurs quand j'ai vu my beautiful
laundrette
pour moi c'est ça me rappelait un peu
curieusement de
le film des clash mais avec scénario
faire typiquement anglais est une
manière d'approcher la jeunesse et ce
qui se passe en angleterre
avec des images crues et en même temps
ça tienne la route chez pachoud et qui
je pense est qu'ils étaient vachement
jeune primé comme ça en fait je me suis
tourné séparer pp mai
il va bien la cinquantaine louis
une espèce de bonhomie comme ça
moi j'ai bien j'aime bien tournage que
j'avais envie en plus pour l'histoire et
âme elle vient de paris sihp amis vu des
cris jamais d'histoire
puis m'a mis pas mal en fait le pied à
l'étrier sûr essayer faire la mise en
scène c'était surtout moi qui décide
un peu de la manière qu'on allait faire
les plantes
mais quand je regarde le résultat je
m'aperçois qu'il a mis beaucoup de sa
manière de voir les planches choyait
mais s'il est plus combien de temps met
pas longtemps après ya dix jours mais
c'est bien tout récent ou leur arme en
vous habitez depuis 20 ans new york
pourquoi qui 27 ans 27 ans oui pourquoi
pas je suis tombé amoureux de new york
un bon je suis arrivé j'avais une
exposition et puis je me suis trouvé
dans cette ville en pleine discussion
les gens se verrait
une sorte d'émulation de travail et je
me suis laissée là qu'il faut être bon
et je suis tombé amoureux de new york ma
première femme à détester donc nous
avons divorcé pas à cause d'une femme à
cause il vivrait vous avez trouvé une
new yorkaise à la fin oui mais je suis
marié
alors là voudraient à paris faisait
souvent par exemple maintenant assez
souvent oui parce qu'il ya comme lorsque
j'étais à new york s'était un peu
endormie paris maintenant c'est presque
mieux que new york art quand même mais
oui c'est pour ça que j'y suis
d'ailleurs même les bonnes raisons de
venir vous ai dit qu'un qui sortent qui
sort aux éditions la différence
aucun parent vous commencez par mettre
un petit peu connu du grand public en
france pour deux choses qui sont
exceptionnelles vaut mieux le dire c'est
les valises et les horloges qui sont la
gare saint lazare non oui enfin les
matins il ya des millions de gens peut
dire enfin et ça ça m'a rendu
extrêmement heureux parce que le jour où
on l'installé ya deux âmes qui passait
vite il pleuvait ouais il ya un qui dit
qu'est ce que c'est que ça je sais pas
ben écoute ça va être pratique pour
donner rendez vous voilà et alors si
c'est ça c'est vous rendez vous aux
valises aux horloges à quelqu'un est là
c'est ça qui se traitent participer à la
vie c'est extraordinaire et biya le long
terme parking qui d'ailleurs on parle de
détruire alors justement je vous en
parlais des écolos ils veulent je plains
les écolos et si vous savez c'est une
association qui comporte trois quatre
mètres a raté
ça vous est venu comment cette île et
les accumulations enfin ça m'a trouvée
prise est déjà dans la nature les bocaux
de cerises la vitrine moi j'ai toujours
été un rêve vitrine
je l'épousé normalement ça j'ai toujours
eu des toujours était collectionneur
j'ai toujours aimé les choses en
quantité
alors c'est venu tout seul je voulais
trouver où tous ces objets mais ça vient
par thierry oui je fais pas n'importe
quoi de temps en temps je suis attiré
par exemple je suis bien connus comme le
stradivarius il vous réalisez j'ai
beaucoup joué au violon mais il ya un
truc à l'acropolis tacler ses moyens
avec des visites power musique c'est ça
c'est très bien ça j'ai vu ça cet été et
en ce moment je fais les broches
mais je suis un nouveau peintre ah oui
c'est retour à la peinture en accumulant
les pinceaux à la france et bien sûr
comme si votre côté kolda nice un
côté couleur et bien
comme disait martial raysse larcher
n'importe quoi mais d'une manière d'être
comme disait chez warhol du show qui
disait je sais pas vous allez me dire
tout ce que je fais c'est de l'art
puisque c'est un artiste c'est ainsi
qu'un troupeau presque du champêtre et
chant il a dit ça c'est de là si je dis
que c'est bien c'est le regardeur
rasmussen lagardère qui fait là oui
c'est vrai ça on en est tous mes
petits-enfants mais bien sûr c'est
génial de warhol c'était le fils de
luchon c'est un des rares filles qui
avaient créé un système presque rien
différence entre un artiste qui fait de
la de l'art et celui qui crée un système
du jeu a créé un système où à laquelle
ce qu'ils assurent qu'ils pouvaient
appliquer un apport d vous avec un
système d'une manière moins net comme un
lieu où on fait un système qui voulait
appliquer à n'importe quelle situation
en a qui disent que c'est un filon en
français c'est vrai non non c'est quand
ils en ont envie pas d'un fil ans oui on
le crée on leur reproche mais on trouve
pas comme ça il faut le qu'une fois le
fabriquer patiemment et vous accumulez
quoi chez vous et trucs que vous
accumulez que vous montrez pas
obligatoirement
les expos mais en ce moment je me fais
une grotte
maison des prix qui se trouvait avance
le savez avec des téléphones j'ai acheté
20 tonnes de téléphone résonne de
téléphone alors la fois les murs tout la
grotte va être mystérieusement tapissé
de télé crochet et votre être
d'accumulation c'est quoi qu'est ce que
vous leur fcdq gérant des fusées ariane
même si j'avais un rêve qu'on n'a pas pu
réaliser je voulais faire une énorme
accumulation une tour et celle de gru
ça pas marché on n'a pas eu assez
d'argent mais j'aimerais bien cumuler
les locomotives ouais les jem avait
accumulé
des avions
salle une trentaine de le boeing ça me
déplaît pas
toujours plus grand
[Musique]
après armand et avant roger vivier
nougaro a découvert new york ça
s'appelle le gaillard
chez son kiné chaque
benoitjura
que faire
[Musique]
j'ai changé
cf
divine
k
c'est dit
je sais pas
ok je suis alors que
j'aurais tout
on en a
les sens
[Musique]
chapka
on sait pas
comme avant ok une pluie de dollars
taillon
super
[Musique]
hors jeu
moi
[Musique]
et
façon jambon durant
[Musique]
roger vivier je connais christian le
bhutan depuis
plus de dix ans il n'a toujours par les
deux bouts avec des larmes dans les yeux
c'est quelqu'un qui adore les chaussures
les souliers pardon oui et m'a toujours
parlé de vous vraiment d'une façon assez
extraordinaire je remercie vraiment
c'est très gentil vraiment jusqu'au jour
où il ya eu il m'a présenté à vous je
suis très heureux de vous avoir ce soir
dans ma 2008 je remercie vraiment je
suis très heureux que vous m'avez
demandé de venir ici vraiment très
sympathique vraiment assuré ville de
pouvoir parler avec vous vraiment alors
vous êtes c'est peut-être un slogan un
peu réducteur et vous êtes le grand
couturier de la chaussure on pourrait
vous appeler comme ça ça bouchonne quand
on est choisi au contraire je vais
vraiment très flatté c'est à dire j'ai
essayé d'apporter dans mon travail en
éléments qu'on avait pas encore utilisé
dans les souliers c'est-à-dire un côté
que tu riais mais c'est
j'ai eu des aventures dans ma vie j'ai
fait des chapeaux mais j'ai toujours été
intéressé par la main par mail côté
couture la mode alors introduit dans les
souliers des des éléments
quinon qui n'avait jamais été fait
encore des souliers on transparente eu
des drapés des choses comment un peu
comme des robes racontez nous un petit
peu votre cas vous ai commencé il ya
quoi il ya environ 27 voix ça fait
vraiment c'est en 1930 en 1903 1904 et
j'avais dû mais j'étais modélistes et
créateur de souliers mais pour tout le
monde et j'ai après je suis parti aux
états unis j'ai fait une carrière aux
états unis et je suis revenu après la
guerre j'étais mobilisés et je suis prêt
voulais pas rester en france paul
d'occupation supérieurs aux états unis
et je suis revenu en france après la
guerre est là j'ai fait la rencontre de
christian dior j'avais une maison à près
de cannes à mougins il est venu
s'installer par hasard à côté de moi et
il m'a demandé qu'est ce que vous faites
je lui ai dit je dessine des souliers
m'a dit j'aimerais les voir mais quand
il a vu mes souliers la dèche pouvait
pas rester à paris
l'un à mougins et je vous à venir chez
moi au plus paris et là j'ai commencé
avec lui pendant deux ans des souliers
sur mesure et c'est celui-là eu l'idée
de le premier qui a eu l'idée de faire
des souliers prêt-à-porter
haute couture oui et alors ça te créer
une ligne de souliers le sujet dior est
vivier et c'est vrai qu'il ya des femmes
qui fera que dior faisait des robes
souvent en fonction de vos souhaits
j'avais je présentais deux fois par an
des collections bien entendu une ficelle
parmi mes modèles le soulier qui était
le plus tôt rappeur avec qu'il devait
émettre avec thalassa ligne à longueur
des robes enfin tout ça mais bien
souvent il y avait beaucoup de souvient
qu'il était tellement étonné par une
forme de talent par des broderies élise
svp rhinos a su lier alors parlez nous
de vos clientes célèbre un peu lisabeth
taylor
les femmes les plus connus parmi les
plus connus du monde elle y habiter
leurs airs ava gardner géraldine kennedy
les altesses aussi mais j'ai fait les
fugues épaules que heureusement car elle
viendra alors est ce que est ce que
c'est vrai que john lennon vous à
acheter des chaussures qui john lennon
vous acheter des souliers wee bb oui
comment ça s'est passé mais plutôt des
souliers pour fans d'habitude nommé chef
et des souliers d'homme aussi un bon
effet des souliers pour nourrir est fait
est fait pour surtout pour quelques
artistes j'en avais beaucoup mais j'aime
bien j'aimerais faire des souliers
d'homme mais je savais je suis tellement
occupés j'ai tellement de travail avec
leurs fans puis on pas jamais oublier de
femmes parce qu'on peut laisser libre à
toutes sortes est fait pas peur des
souliers en tulle pour les hommes quand
même pas encore à pour tous peut-être
alors vous avez fait aussi beaucoup dans
des films très connu par exemple c'est
vous qui aviez fait les souliers de ava
gardner dans la comtesse aux pieds nus
par exemple oui de janeiro d'henri déjà
numéro un journal la femme de chambre
régionale d'une femme de chambre la
grande catherine ouest est le dga
nouvelle que ça avait fait la preuve
j'ai repris la plateforme car elle avait
des robes le xviie siècle 8e et elle est
comme n'est pas très très grand dit pas
laquelle suisse
romy schneider aussi dans le rôle de
maria m'attirer brigitte bardot
catherine et concert de brigitte bardot
bref
coup de fil des poubelles qui a fait des
cuissardes avec elle vous allez porter
sur une motocyclette à médiator
fuyez darren l'angleterre c'était là
c'est curieux parce que j'avais fait ce
dessin mais de personnes devait le voir
début j'avais des
les journalistes des amis qui sont venus
du journal el pais ils sont venus
habiter à mougins ouais et je verrai
monté sur un petit positif je suis
vieille my monsieur on ne dira pas une
semaine après j'avais la page dans l
enfin djenné vous savez enfin sans
apporter beaucoup de chance ça que c'est
grâce à ça que j'ai entendu parler nous
et qui est ce que quelqu'un aujourd'hui
qui peut qui peut vous succéder ce que
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui à des
créateurs de souliers qui peuvent
continuer par unicef 08 espère
percer avec christian et je peux
comprendre les cas ils aiment ça je peux
vous le dire parce qu'il m'arrive
toujours parlé les larmes dans les yeux
on mais je suis sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes vraiment et c'est pour ça que je
vais revenir à paris parce que
j'aimerais avoir mon studio à paris
depuis peut-être travailler avec des
jeunes vous savez qu'ils me voient
travailler plus leur
on va prendre mais qui me voulait faire
et puis
il fait plumer
à travers nous peut à travers noir album
sylvain bergère 18e édition tournage rue
du bourg-l'abbé
le corps a disparu
carling labo bas
surprise c'est un garçon
de nice beaulieu la fiancée de le pen
alpha blondy là didon sol et semble
alégria banda
martin veyron monsieur chabrol
ardisson et sa meuf
corti distrito marianne on sait pas qui
c'est
eric 9
[Musique]
beineix corti distrito
toni kroos jean michel gravier kerno
mauvaise
euh
bingerville
on sait pas qui c'est
roda gil
midas tir l'entrepôt
à l'entrepôt
mimi bastille
oscars le chat de jean marc roberts en
pension chez mme aubert dérive de nuit
pour sylvain bergère ça commence à
montbard en baisse
gare du nord
gare de l'est
canal saint martin
[Musique]
atmosphère
et les champs elysées merci drucker
[Applaudissements]
clan ben amor n'y a pas de remords voici
flashback crosby still nash teach the
children allumé rooryck
[Musique]
tu peux ma
nous sommes
on
m
je ne
qui
ce
[Musique]
une
c'est
m
[Musique]
enfin allez
sud actuelle
là
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'impressionnante okada est pas moi je
fais plaisir loi dans les chouchous de
la cm mais qu'à cela ne tienne il dit
ceux-là
baptisé je voulais amener le pin's oui
ou oui mais il n'est pas sorti par la
peur de michael jackson son succès que
la maison de disques elle va où il veut
sortir le 15 décembre il va sortir quand
pour les prendre comme on l'appelle est
vraiment sous pression parce qu'on
allait porter malheur donc à la non il
n'y a rien de nouveau la corée mathieu
il est vraiment vérifié hier sur une
compilation j'ai amené une compilation
encore il ya des morceaux de l'époque
nous étions très jeunes fréquentent le
voir déjà derrière ça fait longtemps
johnny bristol doit tracer la sainte
avoye la wii à la vente revient à
richard aimera vos sous il ya jackie
wilson mûri que tout le monde ne connaît
pas de webcam
ouais ya quatre morceaux de glace celui
là qu'il ya toute la phase vraiment très
bien oui tous les nouveaux devrait le
connaître maintenant maman c'est en 45
puis un petit clin d'oeil à juju je jure
à la norme grecque ce qui aurait créé
puis j'espère donc tu peux dire que tu
vas être sur scène avec lui mon du jour
moi je voi avec la contador et puis et
puis la semaine prochaine j'espère que
ray autre chose mais très bien moi je
dis moi est ce que tu sais que le 13
janvier c'était le nouvel an russe
je ne savais pas mais ça me concerne
quand même la wii cette région après
nous alors en l'honneur du nouvel an
russe on va voir un clip qui s'appelle
russia ndt c'est bon signe c'est là le
beau blond la douleur est là il est là
ouais
non
le jeudi
[Musique]
ça
m
[Musique]
such as
et pour moi je
[Musique]
oui
il
[Musique]
c'est
chose
g
jean
[Musique]
le millas lobato van hemert volkov
presse mourousi bonsoir alors si je vous
ai demandé de venir tous les trois c'est
qu'il ya deux jours c'était le nouvel an
russe le 13 janvier à pourquoi le nouvel
an russe a lieu treize jours après le
nouvel an il ya pas lieu de 13 jours de
nouvelles on sait votre nouvel an qui a
lieu alors à mort avant
les six mois une explication
scientifique c'est que le calendrier
julien de l'appel lequel tout le monde
vivait le pape grégoire inchangé lequel
on glisse à 13 jours la mesure où il y
avait déjà eu une rupture entre l'église
d'orient l'église d'occident l'église
d'orient est resté au calendrier julien
et l'église d'occident est passé au
nous avons treize jours de distance et
ou alors vous connaissent pour le
montage ya d'autres livres vous avez
fait que beaucoup de succès enfin disons
que le plus connu c'est sans doute que
sans doute le montage vous en êtes où
l'accusé d'avoir un livre qui sort
bientôt j'ai un livre qui sort ces
jours-ci qu'ils se donnent
interrogatoire qui dont je viens de
faire le service de presse de vous avez
dû en recevoir un exemplaire malgré le
temps de voir laquelle je pars et je
crois qu'il sera en librairie dès le 14
très bien alors prince mongauzy vous
êtes parent avec yves mourousi
c'est un parent tout à fait c'est une
autre branche way russes aussi
d'ailleurs et d'origine d'origine russe
tout à fait et votre père et l aide de
camp du non pas mon père
mon grand oncle a été même le premier
docteur de l'empereur nicolas 2 il fut
générale déviation d'autre part et le
premier fondateur d'une école d'aviation
russe il était pilote ce qui était
extraordinaire début du siècle en russie
et d'ailleurs c'est grâce à la france
encore une amitié franco russe que bon
vent donc là pu faire une sorte
d'aviation russe et que ça vous vous
êtes l'aide de camp du grand duc
vladimir qui est le descendant direct du
dernier des arts
vous mme honoré beaucoup et
je pense que si j'ai cet honneur
je servirai de mon mieux le grand duc de
russie actuelle alors ce grand duc de
russie c'est lui il est quoi par rapport
aux derniers cela tout ça les français
connaissent même pas les rois de france
alors les arts pour eux c'est terrible
il étend sa petit neveu il est en fait
son petit nouveau fait son petit neveu
mais le chef de la maison impériale et
comment expliquer que ce grand duc
vladimir on le voit jamais pourquoi il
n'est pas plus en avant pourquoi est-ce
qu'il ait pas plus parce que il n'en a
pas besoin vous savez quand on est le
chef de la maison impériale d'un empire
qui a la taille d'un continent qui est
le plus grand en pis
si je puis dire chrétiens
les plus grands empires tout court si
vous permettez l'expression
et il n'a vraiment pas besoin de se
montrer et il est simplement le chef de
la maison impériale à quoi bon sauf si
elle a nécessité
lui demande où exige une seconde je ne
sais pas risque puisque les russes en
russie connaissent son existence est ce
que certains oui moi je moi je vois pas
mal de russes de russie et beaucoup je
présente à moi comme monarchiste me
disent oh regardez nous sommes au marché
genou ils ont compris que nous on fait
une monstrueuse bêtise nous sommes nous
sommes au large et vous analyser comment
ce qui se passe en russie aujourd'hui
tous les deux avec gorbatchev et
l'assouplissement actuelle du régime là
bas là la pire de tous j'en parlais hier
matin la pierre de touche sur l'attitude
du régime à l'égard de l'église si
l'église si la liberté de conscience et
la liberté de culte est vraiment accordé
au peuple russe alors je crois que les
communistes n'ont plus que pour quelques
semaines et je crois que ce sera un vent
de terre de touche c'est pourquoi ils
n'attendront prendre non pas facile la
corde dans quelques semaines nous nous
retrouvons histoire musique change
mais
et ces jeunes et ça nous
d'un réchaud
cliquez
ici
[Musique]
les essais libres d'aller bruit
car magnéto
pas de basseau banner et
[Musique]
à
quand le magnet doigts
oh
[Musique]
dj hors
jeu dix ans
series de veau d'or
ballon
d'essai ya
[Musique]
récit
les
m
[Musique]
ce
mini série jason
bay
[Musique]
ce
projet
suhamy
des trois jeunes
cambo des rebelles
les arbres et haies
pas de masque
[Musique]
je
parce qu'on venait
elle était alors
que
il est le voeu de
le temps
gauguier amis
je trouvais
et les
[Musique]
l'année
dès qu
aujourd'hui
on
jamais
na
les
l'éclat de son solide
aujourd'hui
pollue bon que
charles
m
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu